SPEAKER: Welcome to Google Cloud
Drawing Board where we doodle
our way through the cloud.
Today's topic, what
is Cloud Storage?
Cloud Storage is a global
secure and scalable object store
for immutable data such
as images, text, videos,
or any other file formats.
You store objects
in buckets, which
are associated with
a project, which are
grouped under an organization.
You can then upload objects to
the bucket and download objects
from it using the console
or gsutil commands.
By default, data at
rest is encrypted.
You have options to secure
it with your own encryption
keys using Google Cloud's
Key Management service
or at your own key management
service on premise.
You can grant permission to
specific members and teams
or make the objects fully public
for use cases such as websites.
When creating buckets,
you have options
depending on budget,
availability, and access
frequency.
Choose standard regional
or multiregional buckets
for high performance,
frequent access,
and highest availability,
Nearline for once a month
access, Coldline for
less than once a quarter,
and Archive for data that you
want to put away for years.
It costs a bit more to
use standard storage
because it allows for automatic
redundancy and frequent access
options.
Nearline, Coldline,
and Archive storage
offer 99% availability and
cost significantly less.
Cloud Storage offers
automatic object
versioning so you don't have
to worry about versioning
and can still access the
older version if needed.
With Object
Lifecycle Management,
you can automatically transition
the data to lower cost storage
classes when it
reaches a certain age,
or when you store a
newer version of a file.
Once you have stored
the data, accessing it
is easy with a single API
call for all storage classes.
Standard regional and
multiregional buckets
are optimal to use for
hosting static websites,
streaming, and
storing documents.
Nearline and Coldline
storage classes
are widely used for backups
and disaster recovery,
and Archive, as
the name suggests,
is best for long term archiving.
Cloud Storage is a
great data lake choice
for streaming and
batch uploading data
for big data and ML projects.
To [? new ?] [? to more ?]
on Cloud Storage,
check out
cloud.google.com/storage
[MUSIC PLAYING]